good morning John you know and probably
a lot of people here know that I am a
bit of an environmental activist this is
something that I care about and then I
think about a lot and so I think a lot
of people were surprised when I did not
talk about the Deepwater Horizon
disaster like I'm an expert and I have a
soapbox and so I should say what I have
on my mind but I didn't and there are
reasons for that first I kind of knew it
was inevitable and I was really really
angry and I don't like being super
pissed off in these videos especially
because the second reason it kind of
makes me focus on blaming people and
that gets really political and really
divisive really fast and I don't want to
do that I didn't want to jump in and be
like it's this small it's kind of my
fault and your fault for driving cars
and still frankly it's not entirely
clear what happened on the Deepwater
Horizon oil rig and how all of the
excellent failsafe systems were not safe
during the fail but I do want to talk
about is oil so let's start out with if
there were no oil anywhere on the planet
starting today we would all die there
would be no economy there would be no
power there would be no water there
would be no transportation there would
be no food luckily for us we're not
going to run out of oil today in fact
I'm going to make the somewhat
preposterous statement that we are never
going to run out of oil now I know what
you're thinking that doesn't make any
sense there has to be a finite amount of
oil on the planet and we certainly do
use enough of it and this is perfectly
true if all oil were equally accessible
we would suck it all up and burn it all
off and then one day we would just be
out of oil that is not the case there's
easy oil to get there is hard to get so
we've got the easy oil actually we don't
have the easy oil anymore we burned all
of the easy oil and it's hard to get at
the heart also you need to do a few
things to get at it you need to make new
technology you need to spend more money
and you can also take more risks and you
can take more risks by drilling in more
environmentally fragile areas where
there is easy oil but if you mess up you
have destroyed something that will never
be replaced or for example you could
drill an oil well three miles below the
surface of the ocean so deep that there
are literally no submarines on the
planet that could get down there to fix
it if something goes wrong or you can
make your workers work 16-hour shifts so
you can cut corners you can force your
managers to do whatever it takes to get
the oil oil finish think of it all is
corporations are are used to risk think
about Microsoft they created this new
phone and it's a complete bomb and then
probably
tens or hundreds of millions of dollars
developing that thing that's a normal
part of running a big freaking crazy
corporation and that's valuing its
Microsoft developing a stupid lame phone
that nobody's ever gonna want but in the
same vein BP can take a risk and they
could say well at most what will happen
will lose an oil rig it will burn and
fall into the ocean and we'll have a big
public relations disaster to take care
of the problem is that BP isn't just
risking its oil well it's risking the
entire Gulf of Mexico ecosystem which is
something that isn't theirs it has
intrinsic value it has actual value it
has actual economic output because oil
companies are risking something that we
all share not just something that they
own that is why there needs to be this
thing called regulation where the
government comes in and says no you
cannot make your people work 16 hour
shifts no you cannot drill at a level
deeper than this and that is why we have
regulators in this country had the risk
of becoming a little bit political here
there is a certain newly emerged
political party that believes and says
that they believe that the energy
industry in America needs to be self
regulated that they should decide for
themselves when something is safe or
isn't safe oh yeah that's a that's a
great plan and see now I'm getting angry
because I'm blaming people and that's
what I didn't want to do but I did it
cuz ah virtually mad catastrophes like
this happen and they will happen more
and more and more as oil gets more
expensive that is what they will do they
will take those risks if there isn't
someone to tell them that they can't in
happier news John and I are finally
selling a t-shirt that says vlogbrothers
on it because that's who we are and if
you like us and you want everyone you
know to know that you like us you can
put it on your body and people will know
it's available right now for pre-order
for two weeks only and then it will
never be available again John I'll see
you on Monday